all right y'all good morning um well
it's actually afternoon sunday good
morning welcome to morning
afternoon water thoughts
um also
we're moving which is exciting we got an
apartment we're moving into a big-ass
pet house
on friday so that's why the wall is gone
anyways um don't forget to subscribe to
the channel like the video
also also okay
um sign up for our memberships because
that's gonna help us pay rent
i went a little too far with this place
but i was like it's so perfect for
filming
yeah anyways if you want to help me not
kill myself over this rent sign up
anyways so today
i'm talking about why it's selfish to be
fat
and how i say this i don't say this as
i'm better than you okay
look at me look at i still got 10 15
pounds to lose i'm going to get there
you wait you wait
as soon as i move like i got my personal
trainer coming in
yeah you wait 10 10 15 pounds okay
and you know i've been overweight i've
been feeling like my bmi is good now i'm
in like the healthy but i'm trying to
get to the like
anyways my point is um
i've been overweight i've been fat
and
it's not fun
and you're selfish now why are you
selfish you think it only affects you no
no no
no no no i have to look at you
why do i need to look at your roles and
then i have to go on social media and
i'll be scrolling
and then boom whale
boom another whale and now you guys on
tick tock which by the way my tick tock
up man i have a new tick tock um
you start tagging me in these whale pit
these whale videos i don't want to see
this
i don't want to see the whales
reason number two why it's selfish
who's gotta take care of you
you got so fat someone's gonna have to
take care of it either your family is
gonna be struck with like hospital bills
and [ __ ] okay
or
maybe your husband or your wife
or your kid why do we have to take care
of you no i understand i don't think
anyone minds taking care of somebody
who you know gets sick has unfortunate
you know leukemia y'all can't help that
but a whale
it's like okay i now have to take care
of you
for your bad decisions the past 20 30
years why why do i have to pay for it
and then in the countries like the uk
where it's free healthcare why does the
public have to pay for it so and then
okay you go on an airplane right and
you're excited to sit down and then a
whale sits next to you
i don't want your rolls to be on my seat
pay for two seats this is selfish this
is selfish behavior
s-e-l-f-i-s-h it is selfish to be fat
and then
now we're going to the beach and they're
saying oh everybody's a bikini body you
know what i barely wear bikinis i only
started wearing bikinis
in the last five pound i i've lost 15
pounds since last year when i was 15
pounds heavier i did not wear a bikini
it is earned
earned
it is not a given and is earned i'm so
tired of seeing these girls wearing
their rolls all over the beach and now i
have to look at it same for you guys put
on a t-shirt
and the other reason it's selfish is
because your spouse has to look at you
now look at you probably are married to
a loving husband or loving wife and they
say oh i don't care that's not true
and this is coming from someone i dated
an overweight dude
and yes i cared
why don't we have to deal with this
get to the gym
get on the treadmill now look at
everyone knows
that at some point bodies change right
over time people get get a little
chunkier we know there's going to be a
little pudge whatever but y'all are
getting to be 300 pounds
and making the general public look at
you
you know what stay if you're over 300
pounds stay in your apartment get on the
treadmill every single day until you're
under under 250
until you're under 250.
because why should we have to look at
you
have you ever you were going out to eat
with like a super obese person
now look it i can't i've been overweight
i've been that person everyone's gonna
watch you eat and it's like
uncomfortable because you're watching
someone slowly kill themselves
and auntie said this it's suicide it
really is
because you're just slowly killing
yourself and you're making everyone
watch you
anyways um i need to go to practice but
i just needed to get that off of my
chest
being fat is selfish if you're fat
you're selfish
on some level and you might say oh it's
because of the kids or oh it's because
of this because of that yo my mom had
five kids and she was six months
pregnant
running a freaking marathon zero excuses
none
no and the other crazy thing is you
don't have to work out you just have to
eat less
if you say i don't have time to work out
fine don't work out eat less
put the fork down debra put the fork
down okay i'm going to practice bye guys